2 forever wars les guerres sans fin
c'est aussi ça le problème de ces
guerres compères pourquoi on les perd
parce qu'on finit par s'user les jambes
bush a déclenché ces deux guerres d'irak
et d'afghanistan sont près de son
successeur barack obama et telus
essentiellement pas parce qu'il est
charmant nouveau il ya tout ça dans la
dans la dans la magie d'obama mais
surtout parce qu'il est sur un programme
anti guerre et parce qu'il sait programs
et des soeurs étaient opposés à l'ira et
sur un programme de retrait des troupes
qui va être perpétué d'ailleurs la seule
seul point commun entre barack obama et
donald trump c'est justement l'idée de
faire venir les troupes à la maison et
là ça pose aussi un problème puisque
barack obama en 2010 décide de retirer
les troupes d'afghanistan d'irak
qu'est-ce qui se passe émergence de
dèche et aujourd'hui donald trump suivi
par joe biden décide de comment de
retirer les troupes d'afghanistan les
talibans reviennent au pouvoir donc on
peut légitimement se poser la question
sommes nous vraiment en train de gagner
cette fameuse guerre contre le
terrorisme
qu'on a initié en 2001 a pris il ya eu
aussi le problème moi je rajouterais ça
aussi essentiel dans ce qui s'est passé
dans les vingt dernières années c'est le
retour de la morale via le
néoconservatisme néo conservatisme qui
est une idéologie qui a issu de la
guerre du vietnam d'ailleurs une certain
nombre de démocrates d'ailleurs ce sont
ulcérés par ses pertes du vietnam ont
décrété que la démocratie devait être
imposée par la force que c'était mort
clarity kong on disait on attend on
incarne le camp du bien et on va montrer
au camp du mal donc il ya eu ce retour
de la morale qui fait qu'un certain
nombre de dictateurs dont on s'était
accommodée pendant des années parlent de
kadhafi par exemple et de saddam hussein
pour les plus proéminents et ceux qui
finalement nous ont donné ces guerre
ingagnable infiné et bien ces dictateurs
pour des raisons économiques pour tout
un tas de raisons aussi sont devenus
tout à coup les nouveaux hitler
[Musique]